when america agreed to take in thousands
of afghan refugees it was with the
understanding that they would be
thoroughly vetted before being resettled
across the country turns out that's
simply not happening according to
reuters at least 700 afghan refugees
have just walked off the u.s military
bases where they were being temporarily
housed without completing the
resettlement process not only are these
migrants now unaccounted for but this
exposes a major crack in this
administration's vetting and
resettlement system joining me now is
wisconsin congressman mike gallagher
congressman i i certainly am sure that
you're concerned about this news
regarding the vetting process you know i
can't i can't imagine that it's all that
surprising though given how much this
entire process has been botched from the
beginning
unfortunately not surprising at all we
have one of these bases in wisconsin
fort mccoy i visited a few weeks ago and
a few things shocked me the first is
that at least at the time when there was
a few thousand there i asked well how
many siv holders do you have here
because you'd think after american
citizens those would have been our
highest priority to get out of the
country the afghans who fought with us
work with us it was zero we had zero
sivs at that time and secondly it was
apparent that by the time they got there
they'd already been given two year
parolee status once they get to the port
of entry usually in dulles airport in
washington dc and then three they have
no way to stop them from just walking
off the base and now we've learned that
two gentlemen afghan refugees that were
at fort mccoy have been charged with
assault and engaging in sexual acts with
a minor so this is unsurprising because
the whole withdrawal has been an
absolute fiasco a fact that was
confirmed to me in the hearing we had
this week with general austin general
milley and general mackenzie where all
three gentlemen tried to spin this as a
success or make meaningless distinctions
like it was a strategic failure but a
logistical success if this is what
success looks like what the heck does
failure look like this has been a fiasco
from start to finish you know part of
the thing that i'm talking about this
week is about the degradation of faith
in american institutions institutions
that used to unite us in feeling proud
of what we offer as a country uh proud
of what we represent to the world and i
think of no institution where this can
prove more damaging than the u.s
military why is it that the military has
become something that where we used to
be able to you know trust it have faith
in it believe that it was going to be
able to execute what needed to be
executed and win wars to one that now
seems to be just another political
football
well i think when it comes to the rank
and file those young marines soldiers
sailors and airmen who are usually at
the tip of the spear we actually have
incredible people in our military doing
a difficult and dangerous job on our
behalf i think the problem is in our
general and flag officer class because
we tend to promote
politicians and not war fighters and
that's a huge problem with a broken
personnel management system in dod as
well as the fact that some of our elite
quote unquote elite war colleges aren't
actually teaching warfighting or the
history of warfighting they've just
become sort of civilianized masters
degree granting programs so we have a
massive problem with how we groom
those officers who show the most
potential to end up being four-star
generals one day and then you have
increasing politicization of those
people wearing stars on their shoulders
it's a huge problem and recent polling
coming out confirms that americans who
used to have you know overwhelming faith
in the military starting to view it as
more of a politicized institution
quickly congressman what can we do to
get rid of this dead weight to get rid
of this problem i mean we can talk about
it brac for generals but how else are we
going to get rid of some of these folks
with stars on on on their uniforms who
really are it seems like not serving the
institution well
well a few things i i mentioned the war
college problem i do think we need to
completely reform our entire war college
and so only the best of the best get to
go and they actually practice how do you
deter china from invading a taiwan in
the most stressing national security
scenarios the second is it really is
actually bigger than any one personality
who's controversial like general milly
it's this entire diversity equity and
inclusion bureaucracy that is being
built within the pentagon and we are
going to have to when we take back the
house go through all of that and
dismantle it because it's actually
harmful to unit cohesion the military
has to be a pure meritocracy and if you
start to view everything through the
prism of race you're going to start to
really screw up our ability to fight and
win wars and that's the final thing our
north star when it comes to the military
has to be the ability to fight and win
wars that's what it's all about
absolutely congressman
very important work thanks so much for
joining me tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else